can you go uh to the fridge to the
freezer and get the candy bars I had in
there I put some candy bars oh part of
the story it's the Shelf you had a day
where you and Stevie like I don't here
were putting candy bars up your [__]
yeah every there a photo of that those
are the good old days yeah those the
good old days let's get candy bars
out is that why you brought candy bars
yeah that's why I brought candy bars I
put them in the freezer first of all I'm
on an ABC show now I'm not sticking
candy ball yeah you are man I brought
here for old time we talk about it yeah
you're going to put candy bars in your
butt oh my God the big kind yeah I
didn't know they're big kind yeah yeah
yeah small kinds too twixes twixes cuz
for like a mini okay okay I don't know
which one but this okay can I say this
okay I swear to God I'm not sticking
[__] candy bars in my B yeah you are
no why would you do this because that's
who you are Bobby this is who you are
I'm a different this is who you are I'm
Different no you're not hateful anymore
you're still
sing I'm not saying go all the way you
try to pull them back out how about this
oh you know what I will stick it in my
butt you know why great great we I can
edit this thing hey sweetie you can it I
think strategically you should go for
the Twix the Twix baby all right please
don't put that payday in there what I
will all right I'll I'll stick you know
me we're editing this part anyway you're
not editing it you'll leave it in oh I'm
not leaving it in you will for sure
leave it in because you're a
man oh
you me but maybe I had you wrong I'll
stick a [__] candy bar in my butthole
cuz I never saw I you never saw you've
heard about it you by way my Netflix
special is out right
now Netflix I mean it's like let me say
something oh my God Bobby
Bob the loop is Bobby oh [__] oh my God
Bobby sweetie careful slowly in in I
can't I can yes you can that's not in an
[__] at all that's in the [__]
butt I'm not scking in smell it smell it
if you want to smell it you SM first
stick it in then I'll smell it if you
stick it I'll smell it smell
it smell it smell
it the let me work the courage let me
work up the
courage this is so ridiculous smell it
smell
it no it smells like chocolate it does
smell like chocolate you you have a
clean careful slowly Bobby slowly George
what the [__] slly do that slowly my
god look look it's it that's it okay
okay okay
okay [__] it out sh out Twix good
this episode is brought to you by
Twix the Great Taste and shit's out
easily oh my God your [__] out the Twix
my goodness oh my God God that was
amazing I show right now holy [__] I've
never been able I've never he's never
even allowed a finger of mine up there
all right cuz not chol enough it's not
chly enough how quickly was he able to
convince you old is that's what comedy
was in the old days you want to hear
something that I did I was I was uh I do
a sports podcast punch Sports I Skype in
cuz I used to do it here and then I
moved to New York so I Skype in and I
was I take shits all the time and I just
like suddenly like are are you [__]
while you're doing this podcast and I'm
like that's a oh okay that's a different
one um and then I'm constantly [__]
showing my dick and stuff and so I was
[__] and lisis Gomez was on was in
studio and he was like and I take my I
wipe and then show it to the camera like
already disgusting and Lou G was like
Hey can you take that the [__] and put
it under your eyes like you're a
football
player and I was like you know but Louis
like I can already see on your face
you're considering it CU you know it's
funny and the shower's right behind you
and you can easily shower off and so
yeah I just do that in my face and then
I was like and then I showered oh my you
know the funnier things going you got to
[__] do it I know but Ari look at
this yeah I got a call yeah from ABC
yeah you know what ABC is for stand for
yeah always butt
chocolate they said stop they said stop
just ease up on the [__] that you're
saying use Twix instead of payday that
is can't be doing like that man I'm a
different come on man I got to dude
television's dead Bobby I know but I got
to stay on a [__] thing so I can make
enough money to buy a house oh okay
why I know I'm not like you into the
wild all right and like the [__]
corporations but you know thing right
now is I you know my dad's going to die
I need another house for my mom to live
in you there's things that I'm looking
in the future I want to marry K have
kids I want to do things man is that did
you just propose was that how you did
it but you know I want to I want to be
able to like you can still do that and
stick [__] up your butt you can be who
you are you are who you are they know
who you are what do they tell you what
do they tell you I don't want to lose
this thing that I have I just want to
keep it cool right you know that you
know what you actually do have
what Pure
Freedom and you're losing that that's
what you're losing I don't think
sticking a a Twix up your butt is really
anything that doesn't that's craz but
that's not racist yeah there are worse
things that they're going to look for
than sticking chocolate up your butt
these white people you got to [__]
you
know you got to get a bow one thing if I
was Asian I'd make white people
bow [__]
you new thing new thing I love that we
everybody thinks Bruce Lee's tough Bruce
Lee wasn't about being tough yeah Bruce
Lee was a light to
immigrants before 196 [__] 8
everybody that was any other color but
white you walked around like in the
shadows you walked around like Harvey
Weinstein in the shadows yeah after
Bruce Lee came he opened up the door to
immigrants immigrants had a voice
especially [__] Asians yeah Asians
were like [__] with me now [__]
I got an uncle who's got Stars you know
what I'm saying like I'll [__] your
world up Asians had way that's what
Bruce Lee was Bruce Lee was a hope for
people black people went crazy how many
black people do you ever see that think
they're Chinese you ever seuck they eat
rice with chopsticks and [__] we the Sho
infused into the hip hopo New York they
[__] them up those black people got
[__] up by kung fu movies yeah if you
grew up in the early 70s the Asian you
loved bro my mother took me to a Santa
Ria dude because I kept saying I'm
moving to
Asia I had the shoes I had the white
shirt with the buttons I go to all dog I
had the white shirt with the blue or
black with the shoes the high cut I used
to I used to [__] burn incense in my
room and my mom with a bowl of rice all
I want is rice you can't eat rice you
can't eat rice all day you got to eat
meat yeah and I would say I'm eating
rice show me a fat [__] [__] and
she would look at me right yeah never
seen a fat Chinese guy just Buddha yeah
yeah except for Buddha yeah it's like
this it's like um you you know I don't
know these kids that get these things
it's fine I'm happy for everyone that
gets it okay but there are just certain
people right that it's just a
given all right you did 25 years of time
into this thing all right and you were
always in it you were never like some of
these guys yeah I I went away for 10
years and I came back you know this this
guy was like me we were in the pocket
when do I always see you why because
it's not because I mean I like seeing
you but it's because you and I have
never quit we never quit yeah we're
always just oh there he is he's just a
part of my reality because him and I are
both guys that refuse to leave the game
we got nowhere to go we're like Richard
G I have plac to go to got nowhere to go
I can go to mountain tops I can go to
cities I can go all over the world if
you would had somewhere to go you would
have gone already no but here's who puts
up with this [__] abuse who puts up
with this people choosing us Netflix not
giving you a special but you're
following Paul Mooney for a year who the
[__] could they to decide that's why
we're so lucky you and I have something
that no other comic has are you ready
for this you know what you and I are
what all you have the Air Force you have
the Army you have the [__] Marines
nav seal you have am nav seal we are the
Navy
Seals to hear it [__] gets danger danger
[__] gets danger who do they drop out of
a helicopter the Navy SE
we're real MIT sh
handpicked us that'll never ever happen
again so who the [__] is anybody to
judge me is there a picture of me in an
improv not really there's not a p you
don't see me on any shows getting
interviewed by Conan you know whatever
I'm saying yeah yeah I've come to that
there another thing that's interesting
is that I go to Facebook right or my
Instagram whatever social media and I'll
scroll through like you know these
younger guys on Conan and all these
Jimmy Kimmel all these things I go
conrat that's great and then it always
in my back of my head like I've never
even been
invited yeah I'll never go I'm on a show
now right a network show they have that
upfronts every year two year two
upfronts they've had so far right I'm
not two yeah do they invite Bobby no
they have never been there and all they
talk about is diversity and yeah I mean
I'm on the show which is great that's
good and that was great but you know
it's like just for laughs Just for
Laughs never been no me
neither now they know yet but you've
never been to Latin Montreal never never
even they said they didn't like the
twitch I did with my hand one year
that's an actual note that was actual
one Bruce Hill well I remember one year
he came out to see me like six times and
then the last time he was just like this
is just no away and I remember my
manager Abby I'm still with her she like
yeah sweetie I'm sorry to noo again this
year and I just remember going how many
years have you been with Abby for 20
plus and who's left with Abby no one
else loyal just you I've been with Matt
Blake for as long as the same thing I
don't leave my people that's aaz yeah
you have to you have to I'm loyal I'm
loyal also that's a well I see people
switching camps I don't like I don't
like are you friends with Asians at home
uh yeah how many
uh that isn't this is the weirdest
question you're the second person to ask
me how many friends I have of a minority
group but was it asked by a minority I
knew yes if I knew the number do you
know how [__] awful that would be if
I capped you guys if there was like a
governor at like
7 I have Asian friends but I don't know
I don't count my high school is like
half asian you didn't have a choice oh
really yeah where'd you grow up uh
Manhattan New York City yeah I know what
man Manhattan it looks like LA
California yeah well I said Manhattan
New York City okay that's fine yeah I
know that's did you hear what I [__]
what you [__] said bro so you were
half of them were Asians yeah it was it
was like it was a public school but it
was like half for smart kids and and I
swear to God the school like half the
kids got in with grades and then half of
the kids got in because you had to let
anybody in because of public school and
I swear to God half of the school is
[__] Asian right did you get angry
about that or no no I didn't get angry
but it was like clearly we know who
earned
it and who they had to
accept any Asians you preferred what are
what are my Asian hierarchy yeah I have
actually an
Asian and it's changed recently after
going to Asia oh [__] cuz I went to
Japan and I was I was like Japan is
number one you know I was kind of
indoctrinated with like the Western
ideology of Japan right and
um I I go to Japan and I have the best
of several things I've ever had in my
life in Japan I had the best steak I've
ever had in my life hands down wow I had
the best pizza I've ever had in my life
Pizza strata in Tokyo I swear to God
isn't cheese a a um a wanted commodity
there they're always making [__] up
everything's a problem with them right
it's like the Godzilla Che everything's
an issue right they're like they're
really just like anxious people like
it's all going away and those comicazi
they just don't know how to [__] land
that's I think that's what it
is oh let's go keep going keep going
push to Jaan push through it push I go
to Japan and I'm like I'm having the
best of of like several things were the
best I've ever had
right but I found I felt like I went
there and I didn't meet a truly Japanese
person or find how they actually felt
about the world meaning everything was a
mask from the gisha to the the [__]
pizza guy like it was I'm going to
perfect other people's [__] or I'm going
to wear a costume that that is how I
should act in the world but I don't know
who the [__] you really are and then you
start to see their porn and [__] and
you're like
oh oh God you restrict people and then
you cause them to go crazy like and and
it was so weird like even the women
there I was talking to a couple of these
Japanese women that had lived abroad and
they came back and they were like it is
an odd thing like the men here don't
want us to be sexy they want us to be
cute
and and it was weird and then you
started to see the girls were kind of
like cute about [__] but they weren't
kind of like owning their sexuality
there's no like there's no like Latina
Japanese Pi like in their sassy and [__]
with the
[__] but like super hot about it you
never pull out a knife defend their
boyfriend
never never dude that har Cari would be
amazing all
right but with a with a little pocket
knife that
like a little butter knife whatever but
so it was just this weird thing so I
went there and I was I thought I was
going to have this amazing experience I
went to that [__] that horseshit
sushi restaurant the the jro Dreams of
Sushi which is dog [__] it was the worst
Sushi I had the
entire absolute dog [__] absolute dog
[__] and let me tell you something and
let me tell you something I came back I
spent
$1,000 I spent
$11,000 in in in $ 25 minutes it was
$500 for my girl $500 for me wa and let
me tell you something I was so I I I'm
curious about other cultures I go there
too learn I was so [__] nervous in
this place that I was going to do
something to disrespect them or like be
rude by accident I bought a suit just
for this place okay just for I have a
whole [__] suit we're there on time
I'm screaming at my girlfriend she is
running in heels cuz I didn't want to be
late cuz they said if you're late you
could lose that reservation we are so
excited she's like a big like food
Enthusiast and we go in and it was
almost inedible no really almost
inedible how
heartbreaking that that morning we went
to the old we went to the old uh fish
market right they have a new fish market
like3 billion doll that they made and it
was amazing you saw like the tuna
auction it was like it was really sick
and we went to the old one to have sushi
and that was the best sushi I've ever
had in my entire life that's the place
and it was unbeliev and it was cheap the
nervousness of being in there affect the
no it's the Wasabi it's you're just if
just you're just snorting M Wasabi
that's what it tastes like when you eat
there and you know what they did
recently I was so happy last week they
took away his Michelin stars that [__]
oh holy [__] dud it's a racket dude you
don't even let Japanese people go it's
like you have to be at a fancy hotel to
get a reservation it's the whole [__] is
is nonsense it's a sham it's a sham it's
a [__] sham a [__] sh and let me
say something I knew this about the
movie because if you saw the sushi in EO
yeah you know how like you're as an
actor or you're even documentary they
put makeup on you yeah they did that
[__] the food the food wasn't even real
it's not real in the food if you look at
the food it's glossy right there's like
sparkles on it almost it glows almost I
just thought that was the quality of the
fish no dude it's Hollywood [__]
magic remember how you was like
everything is about the rice dude I'm
not going to lie the rice was bomb the
rice was bomb the rice but you're going
to get bomb rice everywhere you go but
let me tell you something let me also
tell you something and I'm in a room for
evasions right now and you guys will
understand this I'm not spending $1,000
on r
,000 on Rice like that is if that isn't
the whitest thing like if you found out
that a white man spent $1,000 on Rice
right like you like how did they ever
colonize anyone like who the [__] like
this is $1,000 for Rice we're not going
to do it the tomago was good but that's
egg it's like why am I spending the
macro was good and then that's it
everything was too much it's hard to
make mackerel not good is so mackerel's
already [__] very is a stronger
tasting fish okay I was
livid you are you sold on like the other
types of restaurants like Noma or um
these other ones that cost like she
wants to go to this one what tell them
about the one in Denmark oh you land at
the airport BR no not Magnus is in
Norway whatever dud you no it's in
Denmark it's called Noma it's been like
a top Rene you have to drive 5 hours
into the forest then you have to sleep
there in a cabin the Norway guy that's
mad whatever that guy is this is I know
the whole I know the whole hustle here
keep going I already know I already know
what it's also snowing snow of course of
course of course it's snowing why
wouldn't it be snowing right what else
you have the Battle of moose you know
how you paid you know how you paid
$1,000 for just basically rice you get a
30 course meal at this place in the
middle of nowhere if you give me 30
peanuts that doesn't you know what I
mean it doesn't it's what the [__] but
like you're going to like it because you
have no other options yeah it's true
right it's like you're in the forest and
they're like do you like it you're like
yeah I guess cuz there's just trees out
there like so you have to eat it yeah no
I no I won't do it I'm sure it's good
but part of that is like you go through
the whole journey so you think it's
better than it is yeah I don't know if
you understand this as as a woman as
much as like we understand as men like
trying to get laid Yeah is so much
investment that by the time you do it
you're like oh my God this was worth it
but you traveled into the forest for 5
hours right you did all this thing you
know what I'm saying yes I know what
you're saying boom so we just just serve
it if you give it if you give it and
it's good right away then it's good when
I don't want it yes and I still eat it
it's good the [__] penin what what is
it called the palone I didn't want it
but then I ate it so it must be good you
did a thing last night that was very
European you kissed my hand three times
absolutely is that a [__] New York
thing he thought you were King John O
that's what what it was yeah he said he
got confused yeah I was pay I was paying
respect to the dear leader you were
that's what it no no no I [__] like
you dude I like I've always liked you i'
I've been a fan of you since day one and
when you came in and you started eating
that bull dick on op Anthony I was like
I'm [__] F yeah and why though
because because you're a free [__]
Spirit you're a fun guy you got good
energy you got great energy and that and
I know you're not going to lose that now
but just we say don't [__] lose it
because you come in you're Wild and your
free spirit and you're kind of like me
cuz they call me Chrissy bug chaser cuz
I like to chase
bugs and what I mean by that is you know
guys homosexual Community they go and
they have guys who don't have AIDS have
sex with guys who do have AIDS because
of the feeling of chasing the bug and
I'm not a gay guy but but I do chase the
bug I do go raw dog I'm actually dealing
with residual uh diarrhea right now from
antibiotics I took for long-term chyia
yeahia but I'm good to go right now
trada what's it what's it called what's
travada now it's basically a prophylaxis
for people who are let's say if you in a
relationship with a guy with HIV and so
to continually have to continue to have
sex with them without getting the got it
got you can't wear no condom you can do
it with no
condom I mean if I about it I can do it
with no condom yeah it's a prophylaxis
right but that's still I feel like
that's still like just playing Russian
no that's what I'm saying because it's
the bug chasing that's what it's about I
don't do that anymore I've been I've
been Cel eight weeks I got a [__] in
Denver though I
will he's had [__] about three times
recently like CVS is like cheers he
walks in they know his name just toss a
bottle and they know what's up but I but
I've made a commitment now to my family
and to myself to just you know I'm
celibate I'm only going to have sex with
a woman who I think could potentially
one day be my girlfriend yeah that's
what I'm doing and guys on the side so
you and guys yeah yeah but so then you
um you had an addiction do you think I
was it was a full full-blown sex addict
a full sex addict you know just
unprotected sex with every just wild
just really living life crazy are you
going are you treating that with
meetings and whatnot
groups and I went to one and the lady
told me um she was like you know you're
not you're not as sick as you think um
she was like but you know try celibacy
and it's been eight weeks besides the
one blowing in Denver I've been celibate
with women um no I don't know about guys
yeah there's a couple raisins that's say
it's like oatmeal you have sex with so
many women had sex with so many women
that like ra if a couple raisins slipped
in that oatmeal he wouldn't notice so
many women we call gay guys raisins guy
if a couple guys slipped in there like
raisins he wouldn't taste it raisin
there's a dude that does our I can't say
his name that's just like you really
yeah yeah handsome very funny like you
right but is in kneed deep in puss puss
yeah right I see for me guys like Yannis
and I'm sorry for putting us no no I'm a
married kid I'm no he's Yanni
almost he's he's almost handsome we got
it if I'm just like yeah if you stretch
my eyes a little farther apart just a
little thing everything's a little
disproportion right you know people's
faces are like one inch like away from
being a incel yeah oh
you seen incel photos where like they
they just put the eyes it's like they
they look like incels but then they do
this and then they're Brad Pit yeah
right no that's just exactly all
beautiful people are like that they just
hinge on being really disgustingly ugly
sure just one one millimeter away from
that from that yeah it's true true is
that because God didn't concentrate when
they were making us I don't know I don't
know I I got to be something though
right I know where you're going I know
where you're fishing and I agree I feel
like he right when he made you yeah he
took a day yeah like he's like get The
Chins in right get the right and all
that stuff right and he concentrated
right but with me he went like this and
thre and and and does this guy need a
chin no and he need a billion of us too
yeah a lot of he says we're making up
just Po and just throw him down white
dudes like you he really con well I
think that's I think God's German that's
why and I and I think the wrong people
won the war I'm just no I'm kidding from
2020 you got F me met about Pearl Harbor
what yeah no I'll never eat sushi
they're still the enemy I'm still an
active the Japanese Army no my
grandfather I swear to God my
grandfather fought in World War II and
he wouldn't eat sushi to the day he died
he would say that's he wouldn't he
wouldn't eat it you know what I'm tired
of that I say I think it's stupid when
when Americans go it was a snake attack
they were angry about it right but
that's war war what is Emperor hereo
supposed to call Roosevelt and go yeah
hello you know it's me U how's the
family by the way I'm going to attack
you tomorrow morning you know I mean he
do that you know that's a good point
that's a really good point it's
strategic no they're they're sleeping in
Pearl Hub and they don't know what
coming now go time you I do I'm not if
I'm being 100% honest with you I do
fantasize quite often about sitting in
men's laps but I don't know what that
means
yeah he's got like a sand yeah he wants
to get iny like when he thinks a guy's
really hot he wants to get sit in a lap
he has urges to go sit in their lap like
Giannis Giannis is such a deep thinker
and jannis is such a motivated guy to
read and learn and push envelope forward
and I can't tell you how many times when
I was with my my kids mom when we were
together and everything was going well I
would have a deep beautiful conversation
like looking at a tree about life and
nature and that would get me so horny
that I would have sex with my kid's mom
so I get turned on by men but I have sex
with women you get turned on by plants
and then have sex with women
conversation so in other words I yeah
I'm romantically I I I would say I'm
emotionally gay physically straight
that's how I would describe myself or or
you could just describe it as just a
fully gay man in the closet is's waiting
for his father to die to come out that's
the TR another point I think I think
triceps from pushing down the game so an
Irish Catholic and I pushed out I mean
that's that's a rationalization I come
from a neighborhood where it's like if
you're not a if you're not a cop a
fireman or a criminal and you're
especially pursuing an art form I mean
you might as well just be sucking [__]
it's like they just are like dude where
can you're I know you're on grinder and
it's like n guy I got a kid I'm just
like I I didn't want to be a cop or
fireman but they're like this is the
neighborhood where a cop's firem but you
know the the US is really uptight about
casual dick sucking because um in the
Philippines I I can't think of one male
family member of mine that didn't
casually get their dick suck they don't
can they don't identify as gay they have
families and they husband they just
casually get their dick suck once in a
while homosexuality was way more
prevalent in the ancient world than it
is now it I believe that it was way less
frowned upon people think oh now is the
most um you know best time to be a
homosexual and it's a great time but
it's like back in ancient Greece where
Yannis can talk about that it was every
it was way accept
open it was open yeah a little more open
yeah it's a little more flexible yeah
yeah little more flexible love success
revenge like when I was in high
school when I was in high school right
at the last day of school I this the
hottest girl at school went to my friend
Craig and goes I'll see you over the
summer this and that and she comes to me
and she goes I'll never see you good
luck and she just walked away and I
remember
going right and then I remember a couple
years ago she was like in the third row
of a soldout show that I was doing right
yeah and afterwards I hugged her how's
life this and that and when I drove to
the hotel right I had such a Glee yeah
right it's it's and I didn't
intentionally do it but it's like
success Revenge you know it's so good
it's so good yeah I'm so glad that um I
have only one skill set which is humor
sure right and I was and I had all this
trauma and all that stuff but I want
everyone to listen it's just like if you
can find that one thing right that one
thing that you're obsessed about right
and you do that one thing
rigorously daily you know your life
could still even with a [__] up
background still turn out good you know
so I've had a lot of those do you have a
lot of people that you would want in the
front seat oh my God I have like a list
I have I Revenge fantasies I have a lot
of Revenge fantasies and I have a list
of 1200 1200 1200 probably names on a
list of people that I want sell out a
theater
right sell out of theater with the
Revenge you should do it the Revenge
invite them all give them free ticket
that's like that's like a [__] Wilt
Chamberlain number of people who
offended you I know I know but you know
I'm trying to even do the math and think
how that's possible is that like three
people a day who said [__] you but it it
has to do with um you know I have I have
a mind that's a little delusional and I
perceive things that aren't really real
right right like so if like a comic will
walk by and no regardless of what their
day was like or what's going on their
lives I don't know but if they don't say
hello to me right I I and I don't do
this anymore but I used to write their
little name in my heart right like Mark
Marin didn't say hi to me today right
and he gets into the Revenge you know
what I mean the basket right he in but
it's still out of my crazy delusional F
fantasy mind that does that and it's
unhealthy and so I don't do it now but
I've that's how I survived do New
Yorkers have those same sensitivities no
we you grow up with a lot of I think
scar tissue cuz New York is such an
honest raw place where your kids the
friends you're with when your kids
everyone's just mean to each other and
like sort of the way Comics are